hey guys this is Cameron with motion
science and I am back this week with
another killer 3d camera After Effects
tip for you someone recently asked me
how I would go about making an isometric
view setup and After Effects in the 3d
workspace so this is what I would do so
you can see here in my timeline I've got
a 3d box which is just a pre comp with a
bunch of layers that form a box and the
three box is parented to the box
controller and if I rotate the box it's
also semi-transparent so you can see
this is a box okay so how do we make
this an isometric camera view which has
been a very popular technique for
several years now so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to create a new camera
I'm also going to make this camera 50
millimeter I found that if I change it
to 35 or 28 or 80 it changes the
perspective of what we currently see but
50 sticks with the current perspective
I've also enabled I've disabled depth of
field you want to go ahead and turn that
off click OK and at this point
everything still looks the same
but what I'm going to do is I'm going to
go into my camera options I hit a a on
the keyboard very quickly to open up the
camera options under zoom I'm gonna
change this to 10,000 so now we're super
zoomed in on this box but under position
I'm gonna do the opposite I'm gonna
change it to negative 10,000 so I'm back
out here so I think I want to be a
little bit further out my scene so what
I'll do is I'll go ahead and change the
position to negative 20
so it looks pretty good I'm also gonna
go ahead and create a new null I'm gonna
make that null 3d when a parent my
camera to that null and here's where the
magic happens under rotation of the null
I'm going to change the orientation to
45 35 30 and if i zoom out on my comp
window that looks like an isometric view
and we have it so let me just show this
a little better let me create another
new solid and I'm gonna call this floor
I'm going to make the floor 3d and bring
it to the bottom i layer stack and there
you can see the true isometric angle I'm
going to move the position down on the Z
I've got some lights in this scene which
is why you're seeing the specular there
so yeah there you go there's an
isometric view I'll do is I'll just
duplicate the box layer and I'll move
the position on the X then on the y
and just to show you here's the Z again
but then I'll duplicate that one and
I'll say move it here and maybe on the X
I'll move it down here there you go
there's the simple solution to creating
a 3d isometric view inside of After
Effects with a camera and a null object
so hey if you learn something new please
like subscribe comment below let me know
what you think until next time I'm
Cameron and this is motion science
[Music]